this is the latest ground of a nearly
three-year fight for justice and the
rule of law
families of victims of the explosion in
Beirut port in 2020 are up against a
ruling establishment that has been
evading accountability
today's anger coincides with a tug of
war between lebanon's Chief prosecutor
Hassan awaideat and the judicial
investigator in charge of the
investigation
shame on you this woman cries why should
we lose our children and they remain in
power
no official has been held to account for
one of the world's largest non-nuclear
blasts that's despite many as high up as
the president were aware of the presence
of Highly explosive materials being
stored at a port Warehouse
I'm really angry and I'm discussed with
what they are trying to do to delay the
investigation or even stop it because
they don't feel what we are feeling they
did not go through what we are went
through and are going through now and
they're serving their political agendas
their probe has been repeatedly stalled
the first judge was removed after he
charged high-ranking politicians and the
second judge betar has now been charged
with rebelling against the Judiciary and
usurping Power
judge Batar has support because he's
done the unthinkable and post-civil War
Lebanon going after high-ranking
officials in the political and security
establishment and the Judiciary he may
not be able to implement his decisions
nor conduct legal proceedings but he's
defiant and promising not to step down
and will issue indictments even if he's
in prison
many here are not surprised in a country
with a history of impunity and a
Judiciary that lacks political
Independence
we're seeing as a sequence of political
interventions to derail the
investigation yesterday in one stroke
there was a complete coup d'etat in the
judicial system where the Attorney
General decided to release everyone
although he had recused himself from the
file for more than a year grieving
families have again lost hope and the
investigation has again been stalled on
a day Alexandra one of the youngest
victims of the blast was supposed to
turn six years old